. So I want to do this once correctly and
then I want to move on.
We all know that the impeachment trial against
Donald Trump was a sham and we also all knew
from the start that impeachment would never
remove Donald Trump.
That's not what I want to argue about today.
If you are connected to reality, you understand
that it's not about evidence.
Republicans were simply never going to really
consider a conviction in impeachment.
And if you don't believe that, you're not
going to be convinced by me.
I think we can skip that altogether.
What I want to go through, just one time with
you right now is that in the days after his
acquittal, Donald Trump has in pieces admitted
to the entire basis for the impeachment, which
was previously denied.
He didn't do it all at once.
Uh, he certainly insists that everything that
was done is fine, but he's effectively admitted
to everything.
And the cherry on top was his admission over
the weekend that Donald Trump did indeed send
Rudy Giuliani to Ukraine looking for dirt
on Joe Biden.
That was the kind of final reversal of the
lies that had been told all along.
So after we do this, we no longer will have
to deal with the farcical argument that the
stuff Trump is accused of doing.
He didn't do, he did it.
The argument is, will he be held accountable?
Is it impeachable?
Is it wrong?
All of that can be debated, but the facts
are now very clear.
Uh, so let's start going through this.
We've done individual clips for a lot of these.
I'm not going to play every video here for
you, but you can find our previous coverage
on each of these items that I'm going to mention.
Let's go through the claims.
One by one, it was claimed that Trump wanted
ambassador Maria Von awic out because she
was interfering with what he wanted to do,
which was to get smear investigations of Joe
Biden.
Trump denied it.
He said he barely knew who she was.
All of that stuff that's been debunked.
It was later confirmed that indeed Rudy Giuliani
admitted his role as Trump's personal lawyer
was to quote, get her out of the way.
Referring to Maria Bonovitch, we have the
audio visual recording eventually released
by Lev Parness, Rudy Giuliani's henchmen in
which Parness is talking to Trump about Ivana
bitch, and Trump turns to someone else in
the room and says, take her out.
So that defense is debunked.
Trump knew who she was and wanted her out.
Second, it was claimed that Trump was seeking
these investigations be announced into Joe
Biden.
Now, Trump has not denied this.
He has simply framed it as I was trying to
solve Ukrainian corruption.
So this one's not even in question.
The only question is, was Joe Biden one of
Trump's corruption related concerns in Ukraine,
or was Trump really concerned about corruption
in Ukraine?
And he was dabbling in a bunch of different
things.
Investigations, people as we now know, Trump
never asked for any other corruption related
probe in Ukraine about anything else.
It was just Biden and he didn't even really
care about the investigation.
As people have testified under oath during
the impeachment hearings, Trump merely wanted
the investigation into Biden announced.
Those are not the actions of someone concerned
about corruption generally.
So yes, Trump wanted the Biden smears and
no corruption does not appear to have been
as concerned.
And now prominently Trump is admitting that
he did send Rudy Giuliani to hunt for dirt
on Joe Biden in Ukraine.
They are trying to couch it.
As Trump knows, Rudy is a great, tough investigator.
But Trump said to Fox news personality, Geraldo
Rivera in a podcast when asked whether it
was strange to send Rudy to Ukraine, Trump
says he doesn't regret it and that Rudy was
acting on Trump's orders.
Trump saying quote.
So when you tell me why did I use Rudy?
And one of the things about Rudy, number one,
he was the best prosecutor, you know, one
of the best prosecutors and the best mayor,
but also other presidents had them.
FDR had a lawyer who was practically, you
know, was totally involved with government.
Eisenhower had a lawyer, they all had lawyers.
Now this is a complete red herring.
The other presidents had lawyers.
That doesn't mean they worked in a capacity
to get foreign countries to smear a potential
opponent of theirs for political gain or it
doesn't mean they did any of these things.
But again, piece by piece, Trump admits it
all.
Trump sent Rudy to Ukraine for Biden investigations.
Trump wanted Ukraine to announce Biden investigations
and didn't care about any other investigations.
Trump wanted [inaudible] out of the way.
And of course, importantly, Trump did order
the military aid to Ukraine withheld until,
and if Ukraine announced the Biden investigations,
ultimately they got caught.
So Trump released the aid, the Trumpists insist
the aid was released without the investigations
being announced.
So it's all good.
This is like saying he failed to commit the
murder despite trying to commit the murder
because somebody caught him in the act.
So therefore it's not a crime.
It's not a defense.
So consider the way that every claim has fallen
apart for months.
They said Rudy wasn't there as a government
operative doing stuff for Trump.
And here is Tom Trump telling Geraldo.
Yeah, I sent Rudy there.
So the new defense is, it all happened, but
none of it is illegal.
The goalposts moving and the standards changing
before our very eyes and on and on and on,
rolling towards possible reelected, scary,
scary stops.